lahter with Crowder studios protected
exclusively by Walter
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right we have a very special show
for everyone out there it's a little bit
different and we are going to have some
announcements regarding mug club while
everyone else is kind of shutting down
slowing down I've been taking the
precautions we're going to do more to
serve you but I don't want to waste time
with that right now we'll have another
video on that I wanted to bring on a
very special guest full disclosure this
is why I brought a Mont I know him I
love him as my own personal doctor
he's an internist in Las Vegas Nevada
he's been practicing for 21 years and he
does I want to make it clear stuff dr.
Choi thank you for being here how would
you describe what it is that you do
because when I went and saw you you did
all kinds of different things and it was
very weird to me that you were a doctor
who actually listened well what I do is
uh what basically other internal
medicine doctors do I'm a doctor for
adult and poor certified internal
medicine and so I serve as a primary
care doctor for my adult population
patients so with that I mean I'm
supposed to be a jack of all trade or at
least know something about everything
right and then specialists are the ones
who just delve into one or two one or
two field right of the vast medicine
fields so cardiologists only deal with
the heart
I'm a deal with a little bit of
Cardiology but a little bit of a kidney
and a little bit of everything else and
now dr. Choi I'm detecting a little bit
of an accent is that is that polish a
lot of people think I'm Chinese but I'm
Korean oh very very small Korean accent
I came to the state's when I was 11 or
12 almost 12 so I've been here about
over 40 years now good career or bad
career you know so you think you
probably have some unique insight
because right now we're talking about
you know coronavirus we flew all this
it's as much of a cultural and economic
you know we're seeing a ripple effect as
it is just medical so so being from from
South Korea and obviously a
long-standing sort of I guess feud for
lack of a better word
with China yeah do you do you feel like
you have a little bit of a different
insight into this well in some ways in
the sense that I used to I still have
some family members in Korea including
my brother who went back after growing
up here so I've been actually talking
with my brother so I have some ideas to
what's been going on in South Korea in
in relation to corporate 19 and yes I
think their relationship with China
right now is a probably a good term at
least related to the virus so the
Chinese have they were actually released
a lot of a lot of info on the virus to
South Korea and that's why they were
able to make the kids to rapidly test a
lot of their population I'm talking
about Korea so they got the sequence of
the virus from China in the some time in
first part of January and that's what
they used to actually come up with the
kids now when did we get that in the
United States when did we know when
China send it to us they may be working
with a US FDA to try to get those kids
approved so we can use it here but
that's a hearsay I'm not sure right all
right well okay so we'll go back to that
with South Korea in the United States
and sort of the CDC I know you and I
have talked about that a little bit but
before we get to that there's there kind
of two sides here there's there's
pandemonium there's panic with some
people and then there are some people
who think that there's nothing going on
at all we've maintained that listen take
the proper precautions but we don't want
to [ __ ] the entire economy there's
somewhere in the middle so for people
who may not be in the know as someone
who has had to deal with this yourself
how bad is it
the corona virus how should people be
viewing this right now yeah
the corona virus is a virus much like
the flu but it is more spread faster and
mortality from the corona virus the
novel virus is higher than the flu
partly because we don't have any vaccine
for work and we don't have any
treatments because you're so new but it
is yes we do need to take this seriously
I mean this is a national
emergency we do need to take this
seriously but this is not like a nuclear
fallout runs not gonna last five years
ten years we don't need to be panic we
do not need to hoard toilet papers we
don't need to do that yeah it's going to
pass this is going to pass but we just
need to actually follow the instructions
from the CDC and our government and
actually do our part right and we can
hopefully get through this with a the
least amount of mortality right we can
only do that if we actually follow the
instructions right
yeah spring according to the paper I'm
the worst person for that because my dog
Betty she eats so that's your thing just
all the paper rolls I came home
yesterday I'm like that's Betty that's
my 401k paper and throws it all around
well that's important right now
obviously people are there's ears being
the blame game and then finding out how
this happened so we can avoid it in the
future because now there's a lot of you
know sort of Monday Morning Quarterback
people say well we should have known
what do you make of a lot of people
right now blaming President Trump in
this administration that they haven't
handled this properly it's that that's
what they've been trying to claim in the
media I is always 20/20 and whether our
president could have done a better job
or not I don't know you know but well
hindsight is 20/20 right now what we
need to do is actually follow the
recommendations that are given to mr.
Trump from his experts the musicians
right and right now the best thing is
stay away from each other just stay away
from each other so that we don't spread
it hopefully if we do that we can
actually dramatically curtail the
spreading of the virus so there in a
month or so we will still have some
cases but it'll be much less right if
this works then we can really get it
under control so I mean that's the key
right it's about flattening that that
that curve and I wanted to ask you going
back to that well first off you said
novel coronavirus and I think a lot of
people don't know this you know I have a
I clean my wrestling mats I have a home
gym with an industrial cleaner and it
says on their kills coronavirus I
think some people may be ignorant to
that like the crota virus has been
around for a long time that's why you
said novel coronavirus cry can you
explain the difference folks minute well
we've had a corner virus for a long time
but this is a mutated is a different
strain basically so we've had a cyrus
our scope one this is we call it's our
scope two so this is a new strain that's
mutated okay so we've had a corner virus
for a long time this just happens to be
a different strain and it is more potent
than the SARS and we know that because
it has caused more death and the
spreading is faster and it spreads a
little easier a little easier with more
deadly than stars like we had SARS in
the Toronto Airport you know us from
Canada aronia virus is more deadly than
that because I'd read different
mortality rates yeah right now the
mortality rate is daresay as high as I
can three percent you know which is
higher yeah okay so and that's that's
predominantly obviously people who are
elderly and people who are have
pre-existing conditions they're the ones
who should be most concerned exactly the
younger patients younger patients really
have good immune system and we can fight
it off and almost most of the cases at
the coroner does covet 19 the symptoms
are very mild we're fine large most
people they get it there it'll be like a
flu-like symptoms and they'll get a
little fever some cough and then they'll
recover right you see the elderly
patients and the people would
immunocompromised a sight diabetics or
heart disease mm-hmm I am supposed to be
a little bit of a higher risk though
because I had a heart attack the
beginning of this year the people with
heart disease or cancer and so on those
folks are a much higher risk of dying
from it so I saw some statistics the
other day and pull over the age of 80
mortality is as high as about 15 percent
right and key point there 70s are about
8% below that I mean the Bortas very low
right so guys predominantly for the
elderly folks so really they need to but
they need to be very careful
yeah let me let me propose this this is
gonna be something people get really
upset this is this is just what we've
had to handle in the office so let me
explain why I'm saying this here and you
can shoot me down as is totally out of
left field here in the office we've made
sure that people are basically
quarantine themselves outside of the
office and then we come to the office
because we're a small enough company we
can keep track of it except for some
older people and I say older I mean like
58 so they're not really high high risk
but we wanted to take precautions
keep them away and I wanted to do a
corona pack where we all like to pop
popsicle stick so that we could just get
it over with but no one else would sign
up errantly my lawyers that's a
liability so but here's my question
we're talking about quarantine in the
whole country
what about just quarantine old people
they're old people and people who are
sick because you know I'm real I'm the
UK they want the herd immunity where
they want it to get the 60% of the
population and obviously that's that's
that's an [ __ ] thing to do if you
allow that to happen and old people who
are at high risk are exposed but it
seems to me that maybe instead of
quarantine the whole country if we
quarantined people who are most at risk
let the virus run its course so people
are no longer carriers and then let them
out of their their cages that maybe this
is just a layman I'm not a doctor what
do you think no nothing there's nothing
to that I'm not saying kill them I'm
saying just keep them safe because
otherwise they're going to constantly be
exposed to this virus until we get a
vaccine right for them it's still
obviously less risky but it's not any
less dangerous if they contract it for
five six months from now that's the
concern not so much for young people
carrying it so just quarantine you know
old people know I mean it doesn't
interest the idea that's an interesting
idea but part of the problem is I don't
we don't know how it's not cake if we
take this approach to get 60 percent of
the general population young people to
actually get infected and recover from
it
music wanna take six months these are
technically the three months six months
or a year right so from
16-point you know how do we quarantine
somebody for six months or a year right
yes that's one thing and then too we
still have young people who can die from
this right and yeah do we really want to
run the risk I mean uh so it's kind of
ethical so we're probably trying to take
the approach where we're going to try to
minimize the spreading of the virus and
let it kind of died off well they're
doing that but there's yeah yes yes if I
assume we didn't bring dr. Troy for Qian
okay I understand yes but we're looking
right now at trying to stop the spread
and then the talk is if it doesn't work
full quarantine and so I'm saying before
that quarantine most at risk if we're
going to go that route and again some of
this is hearsay but I mean that's that's
pretty scared to a lot of us and I know
you know you probably have some more
insight on this when people point to
South Korea's being successful you and I
have spoken on this it's a very
different culture and the kind of
approach in South Korea are not measures
that necessarily would be acceptable to
Americans or work can you tell me a
little more about that yeah remember
Korea is a very small country and it's
very a centralized government so I mean
they can mobilize much faster than we
can in some ways and the people are very
densely populated and this is why the
using the masks end zone work
it was probably necessary for them
because they're in a crowded place and
they're always going to be in contact
with somebody but for us maybe like you
know someone like in New York perhaps
you know that might be an issue but like
in Vegas were where I'm at the density
here is very low so we could actually
stay away from each other much easier
than people in South Korea so we don't
really need a mask you're right we don't
really need a mask and it's not right
now because we can get the virus just
standing out here and it doesn't exist
in the air by itself it has to be
transmitted from another person to the
next
see I think this is important as I
wanted to have you on there are
conflicting reports for some places say
it is airborne and then some places say
it's only transmitted through contact so
it is only through some kind of contact
or or you know sort of contact by proxy
well contact mainly what we're thinking
is that uh it is my contact like if we
shake the hands of another person who
has a virus or if we actually touch the
surfaces
soon after somebody who has a virus
touches a surface and then we touch our
face with it right because he enters
through our eyes or nose or mouth so
it's it's a respiratory virus but we can
also get it it can be airborne it's
typically not it can be airborne or
droplet so if somebody coughs at us and
then we can actually inhale that and we
can get a we can get the virus infection
or right so the person who has a virus
has to be in close proximity and cough
okay and then we can actually come in a
cup of the virus and then we can
actually inhale that so if that's that's
pretty temporary it would actually have
to be like you're talking about you know
basically a fine mist in other words
it's not necessarily airborne just
because someone was breathing there 20
minutes ago no and it does become
airborne it does become airborne in the
cases where like in the hospital if
somebody has the virus and if you use
like nebulizers or if you're like you're
suctioning the airway that can actually
make it airborne but it doesn't last
very long I mean it's not gonna be in
the air for a long time okay it's gonna
die off so you have to come in contact
with somebody for a significant amount
of time in order to actually uh inhale
never gonna get the virus what about you
being a doctor do you wear I noticed
you're not wearing you don't look like
Bane right now I notice that you're just
yourself do you wear a mask right now
all the time when people come in or a
respirator no absolutely not no okay
well what seemed pretty bold with that I
would be scared why not why not well at
least in Nevada right now even in the
hospitals will not routinely prey on
masks right mm-hmm
we're we've actually locked down the
hospital so there are no visitors coming
in
and and then even the staff everybody is
screened with a questions and the
receive their fever or symptoms and if
they're dealing with a patient member
I'm sitting here and I am NOT being
exposed to anybody right now
all right there's absolutely no reason
for me to wear the mask it is not going
to accomplish anything because there is
no coronavirus in the air right now
right it's only if I'm in the close
vicinity with a patient who actually has
symptoms or who actually has infection
so if I'm at you treating a patient who
has symptoms of potential coronavirus
then I will actually put my ninety-five
mask on I'll put my gown and gloves on
okay but otherwise I'm not putting any
uh personal protective gears or PPEs
equipments right and what kind of that
is the CDC recommendation CDC
recommendation is that general public
does not near the need to wear the mask
at least not yet and the health care
workers we do need to wear if we're
dealing with the patients were the cook
with 19 or suspected patients right but
it seems I've also read that really the
reason there tell me well not to wear
these masks is is more so because of the
shortage that they're still if you if
you have them it's not a bad idea to
wear them but specifically if you have
the virus that you should wear the mask
yourself and then if you don't and
you're around people who do that's where
you want the the n95 respirator that's
incorrect
okay much of a question in there that
was that was my fault as an interviewer
not yours as a doctor you can diagnose
me as a book later okay to be safe and
protect yourself which dr. Choi are you
protected online you protect yourself
online the good news is expressvpn
anonymizes everything they encrypt 100%
of your data they were voted the number
one VPN on the market and my radar
wire and the verge and they haven't had
any break-ins like data breaches like
others and other VPNs out there and
people watching right now can go to
expressvpn dot-com slash crowd or to get
an extra three months free so dr. Choi
if you're not protected online that's a
expressvpn calm slash crowd or for an
extra three months free and you can use
on all your devices so that people don't
know what you're looking up you know
that your South Korean your mistrust of
the Chinese government they could be
keeping an you know watchful eye on you
there nonetheless if you use expressvpn
let me ask you again about about South
Korea do you think that also I mean
we're kind of joking about this but
they're somewhat mistrust of China
having worked with them for such a long
time helped them get ahead of the curve
because they were skeptical or in
looking at the information presented to
them whereas here we'll get into it the
CDC in China has been a it's been a
nightmare as far as the false info I
think they do have a little healthy
skepticism the Korea mobile as really
quickly and early on and it's just
massively tested a lot of people and
they were tracking every case to see
like the four says uh within 24 hours
wouldn't know like they were four hours
to 24 hour till get the result and if
somebody does have Koba 19 the day will
actually track use all means to track
where that pay a person actually went to
so they'll look at their credit card
spending they look at a GPS systems to
see where the patient went to and the
partner actually let the public have
that info so that the people can avoid
where the patient went to so they
apparently they use a system rather
nicely to slow down the spreading of the
virus
rather than massively quarantine corn
getting everybody so effectively the
South Korean government doxed its
citizens and that's if that might be so
that Americans aren't super comfortable
right with right the right it's the
American so in other words when people
say look at South Korea and the failure
and this was a question I was getting to
what why did it take this much longer
people are saying we're more inefficient
here in the United States I think the
answer the question is to all Americans
out there watching are you comfortable
with the government tracking you using
GPS and releasing that data to the
public because that's how South Korea
got ahead of it oh look he's not if
you're a busy man you're on your phone
is that we were doing your tape have I
bored you this much dr. Troy I get that
I'm just I'm just a basic Caucasian here
but come on you're the most boring
person I know
[Laughter]
No so that is yet they literally were
tracking and then releasing that
information to the public to have that
those kinds of results here which would
be harder because it's much bigger the
United States government would have to
do that with its citizens well plus is
much much a bigger country and we're a
much bigger this is it geographically
were much bigger and we're also very
diverse population so it just doesn't
it's not going to apply what they what
they've done over there it just doesn't
apply here
mascius you were talking about you know
when we were talking about people sort
of blaming Donald Trump and he said well
no really the CDC doesn't have a whole
lot to do with President Trump the CDC
also wanted to correct me from won't go
into China and offer help a while ago
and were denied correct that's that was
the information I had it's that close to
society China right right they practiced
don't want to accept help from Western
Western country right well and what
we've been told in the media is is you
know that President Trump told the CDC
not to prepare now as someone whose work
is it is is that true there any truth to
that I don't know I mean I I don't
understand why anybody would tell to CDC
not to prepare that's up right yeah well
yes it would be awfully unusual and
typically speaking the CDC doesn't
really have a whole lot to do directly
with the president in that capacity I
know they mentioned the pandemic task
force our team and the guy who was there
said no that's actually not true we
weren't disbanded at all we were we were
streamlined and this is I guess a
question if somebody works in medicine
right we've seen this with psychology
psychiatry a lot of a man and we see it
now with the media a lot of Americans
don't necessarily have the greatest
amount of faith in their institutions
and we've seen for example the FBI and
the DOJ they can be politicized is that
also possible with agencies like the CDC
because we see or or the word
world health organization do sometimes
these different organizations have
different political agendas where it
makes it hard to sift fact from fiction
I'm sure every organization whatever
field it is their end
all right does have some that can be
influenced to an extent by politics I'm
sure you know that's just uh that's just
the way it is right but but I would
imagine organize a organization like CDC
would be much more driven by its
scientific data and for the public good
yeah and CDC has been sending uh you
know I do get a regular update from CDC
on a regular basis about the October 19
and what we're supposed to do so I mean
it's not like they haven't done anything
they have been doing things initially we
didn't have all the proper information
from China and so we probably with that
this wasn't a huge deal and then later
on you know with you know it's spreading
in South Korea and uh Italy in the
Europe and we start getting more
concerned but we still didn't have a lot
of cases here and as far as we know
really know that until I believe
beginning uh recently and that's what I
always said okay now it's actually uh
spreading here too that's when we start
getting much more concerned right and so
I think this is important to note a lot
of people think that the United States
is unique we are unique in a way that
you've sort of drawn attention to were
large were we're very diverse compared
to a lot of other countries but we're
not unique in that up until more
recently globally this wasn't seen as a
big concern based on the information
that we were getting from China everyone
was kind of in that boat until not too
long ago the World Health Organization
declared a pandemic on I believe that
12th March 12th wasn't it 11:30 12:00
12:00 so you know that's that's not
thing you know that's what we really
start getting concerned and the schools
are shutting down and Nevada is on a
basically a kind of lockdown at this
point all the non-essential or business
have closed as of yesterday and all the
casinos have closed so only the
essential businesses have stayed open
such as medical practices and the gas
stations and the food places where they
you know like no supermarkets right so
on what about what about weed and
hookers in Nevada are they still in
business still going they're open
drive-thru dispensaries there and in
Nevada I think that sort of answers my
next question then because it matters to
get to the root cause of why did people
not think this was an honest it doesn't
like you said this isn't the kind of
pandemic that is going to kill twenty
percent of the population like people
have missed reported initially but the
reason that people didn't take it as
seriously as maybe it as ended up being
is because of the information we're
having you know according to the doctor
Lee Young who was actually the
epidemiologist who dealt with a SARS
in Hong Kong he said with this covert 19
the mortality can be as high as 40% and
the 60% of the world population in a in
the worst scenario in the worst scenario
or 60% of the world population can be
infected and of those 40 percent
mortality can be up to 40 percent
that's the worst scenario but but you
know we also know from what the South
Korea has done and also what China has
done it can be contained it can be
controlled and we can actually get
through this without that kind of
devastating number and this is why this
is why the u.s. is now taking the
there's a drastic measure where we're
actually trying to do lock downs and
have the people not come in contact with
each other for about a month to try to
avoid that kind of potentially having
that kind of a pandemic right and right
and I don't think we're gonna have that
because we are already taking their
measures we're taking measures so I
seriously doubt we're going to have
anything
do that okay so we don't need to be
panicked we don't need to be panicked
right the best thing we could do is a
simple I said a simple measures such as
washing our hands very frequently and
don't touch our nose don't touch our
face without washing right and wash our
cell phones are frequently throughout
the day and if you if you're out try not
to touch your public places and just try
not to go out if we can for a while
until we get this under control right
but I really doubt we're gonna have a
60% of u.s. population infected I really
now we're gonna have 40% of those are
dying I just probably not gonna see no
no touching on this but that does sound
like from what you're saying that means
that playing a good old game of head and
shoulders knees and toes eyes ears mouth
warehouses out that should be no date
yeah right now your killer at that game
okay it's not even a game I thought it
was a limerick but as a practitioner how
urgent is it for you to get the the
testing kits cuz that that seems to be
the focus in the media right now as well
we don't have enough we don't have
enough testing it sounds to me like
maybe you're saying it's that's not as
necessary as taking these these
precautions and these measures or have
you been disappointed in the lack of
testing kits available why don't we have
testing kits it sounds like we've sort
of answered it by the root cause I'm not
having the right information but as a
practitioner well what's your point of
view on that I do I do have some testing
kits now okay I do have some custom kits
initially we were rationed uh about five
last week but we now actually have
proper twenty thirty of them a big
increase I mean I don't think a lot of
people who dr. Giants don't skimp ass
that don't get don't play coy most
people think that there are no testing
kits available that's a that's a for art
there are testing kits there are testing
kits and the hospitals are testing and
so we're gonna have mobile testing
places apparently where we're going to
be able to test people as they drive
through just like they did in South
Korea so right then we're gonna have
those so we won't have more kids so U is
coming but we still need to try to slow
down the spreading bye
away from each other I get it we can't
be touching our faces I understand this
document I get it I thought I didn't
know you were a pediatrician
but this is so you'd like like a sort of
like a taco truck but for coronavirus
testing kids correct do you know why you
went from five to thirty is a big part
of that because they've been recruiting
sort of private laboratories now to to
assist in creating more testing kits
correct so the big private labs like the
quest
LabCorp they have the capability of
doing the tests and now the they've had
approval from the FDA or CDC crest to
use more of the regular swabs to test
okay so that's that's why now we have
more kids now why was that not approved
before what's the difference between the
regular swabs and the other swaps well I
think they just didn't know if it was
going to work so they they probably had
to test it okay so yeah it seems like
there's a lot of red tape there and it
seems like this is a good thing though
that at this point had we relied only on
the the federal government we wouldn't
able to get as many kits this quickly so
having private laboratories working in
you know sort of in tandem with them
seems like I mean you went from five to
thirty that's that's a huge bump correct
yes okay so that's good so there's a
silver lining there and I do you know I
want to ask you about your health but
it's being which you'll I see it you're
drinking coffee but I don't think you're
drinking a the right coffee we're gonna
send you some with black rifle cough you
know there veteran owned and they
fresh-roasted ship it to your door
they're huge they have the balls to
sponsor this show with you and they're
offering a discount right now people go
to black rifle coffee calm slash crowd
or use a promo code crowd or they get
20% off their first purchase I'm a big
coffee snob dr. Choi and I don't like
what I'm what I'm hearing about what
you're drinking there at the office that
to me is more concerning than Caronia
sorry yeah right yes yes adapt well
there's mold there's Myto toxins I know
I read Dave Asprey I know what I'm
talking
are you a medium roaster dark roast guy
doc Brooks doc roast it sound like you
said duck roast duck no okay yes you
have my accent yeah so you've been in
the United States for how long 42 years
that I could hear that explains it the
accent only goes away at 44 44 years
you're just under the courrier yeah
we're you and when you let when mess
around corn let my french-canadian mom
no because figure that out really but
dr. Choi
you just you'd mention the sort of
nonchalantly that you had a heart attack
that was a big surprise me when you when
you told me that I think it's a big
surprise people watching I mean you're a
trim guy I've always known you to stay
healthy and you eat pretty pretty well
and you certainly have have helped me
with how did that happen a relatively
young fit healthy guy have a heart
attack well doctor thank you heal
thyself I guess I had a high cholesterol
and I thought I could control with a
diet and exercise which I've been doing
and obviously not that's one and then
two you know my job is very stressful
mm-hm and then three there's a family
history of early onset heart disease and
I kind of ignored that I guess so
combination all of those probably led to
the earlier attack and do you think you
maybe ignored it because you felt so
good and you were kind of fit and spry
yeah I'll be fine
correct because uh I've been eating
healthy and I've been exercising with a
trainer or a long time many years and
you know I run on the treadmill I don't
have chest pains like okay so I thought
I was okay
obviously not you know what that brings
me to interesting point and I think it
may also relate to this you know the
Cova 19 but um
how important are genetics in health I
think often we overlook that well first
let's start with that genetics how
important that because that seems to be
the sort of new frontier with health
genetic testing not even talking about
gene doping which I don't understand but
genetic testing is it is important
that's kind of the the directional are
the the new
technology's going to the China figure
20 occasion actually works better for
this particular individual based on
their genetic disposition you know so
that we've been doing a study on that
for quite some time and there are
companies out there who are testing to
see which medication I should be giving
each individual because you know there
are like maybe there are 10 different
medications for one condition and there
are they may not be all equally
effective or a practical individual or
one Mayo or some of those medications
may cause more side effects on a
particular individual and we are
actually trying to figure out how to
test right the genetic testing to apply
to that but you know we're still in a
we're still not there no in my opinion
but it's getting but you know it's
getting more accurate and my second
question is because you said you have a
stressful job how much of an impact does
a lot of bill thing about diet and
exercise how much of a physical impact
because stress in seeing is a physical
thing right you get in the gym you get
in the treadmill healed okay I'm
physically moving or I'm physically
moving this way to benchpress room
physically putting this food in my mouth
stress is sort of conceptual for a lot
of people how much of a physical impact
does stress actually have on one's
health because of stress we know that
will it will decrease the immune system
mm-hmm stress will decrease the immune
system so obviously uh if your immune
system is lower then you're more likely
to catch the virus not just corner virus
but any other virus right right yeah
they're in infections yeah but this
podcast will be titled about Coronas
because that's what sells so that's what
we're told normal flu so so that's
something that's known right in the
medical field I mean that's a physical
observation stress lowers immunity that
can be quantified yes and I guess what
other in closing here what other tips
would you give if you had to tell we get
it wash your hands social distancing but
is there anything else that you think
maybe some people can take as extra
steps are there or they're missing
either whether it's lowering stress
whether are there any supplements or
anything that you think might be not
we're not saying
a cure but is there anything that you
would also advise on top as
supplementary measures for people to
take precautions there are some there
are some data or suggestion that the
zinc may help is that there are some
estas that were done where the zinc has
shown to slow down the replication of
the RNA from the virus okay
intercellular replication so the zinc
potentially may help but there is no
absolute data that says it does or the
Cobra 19 but generally speaking you know
it may help so sure it's not going to
hurt you take some zinc supplement okay
and there was some initial there are
there some antiretroviral medication HIV
medications were used with some success
in treating the patients but that's in
the hospital right or anti-malarial
medications such as which is a
hydroxychloroquine they've also used
that in South Korea and in China to
treat the severe cases well I just read
about that today and that's relatively
new how does that work like you've seen
this anti-malaria medication because it
seems like there's a lot of promise
there and it's it's a little weird to me
that they've been using it for a while
overseas and it hasn't really been
discussed until this current 24-hour
news cycle there's some mechanism
apparently the chloroquine or the
hydroxychloroquine may assist in the
transport of the zinc from extracellular
to intracellular where it is needed to
stop the replication of the virus but
that might be the on mechanism um to be
honest with I'm not exactly sure but but
that's uh that may be the mechanism but
they have been using it to some degree
of success correct Wow
yeah at least the report from South
Korea and the China well I trust a
report more from South Korea than China
it was only coming on China but South
Korea you know you guys make good phones
you know I've never had Korean food that
I didn't like
the Samsung Galaxy seven exploding in
people's faces you have to admit that's
that's one for you guys that was a
little bit of mess up but aside from
that we've had a pretty good
relationship with them all right well
thank you so much doctor I know I know
that you are a busy man
and you have a lot of patients to get to
so please do take all precautions that
you can to stay safe I know I'm saying
this you're the doctor and you know if
there's anything that that happens it's
new that you think the public should
really know about please do let me know
or let them know because people are
desperate for information out there
right now and they're looking right non
politically charged sources to give us
the straight straight story and I think
that's very hard to come by right now
unfortunately yes well thank you very
much
sometimes a man a few words and then
sometimes a man of intense mockery did
you notice that
yeah he's mocking me for everyone
watching right now we appreciate we
really appreciate taking the time and
we'll have some big announcements here
coming from Mudd Club and the kind of
content that we'll be doing for everyone
out there and everyone else's stepping
back I think we're going to be stepping
up and trying to make it worth your
while because we know that a lot of you
are lonely out there we want to help
with that as much as we can thank you so
much dr. joy everyone else we'll see you
next week
[Music]